a Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance making America safe is my
number one priority began the message
from the President of the United States
and the rest of that message naturally
one would presume one would believe one
would pray continued and so I am
declaring the United States territory of
Puerto Rico an important part of this
nation since 1917 and the wellspring of
so much of our culture and industry and
the joyous celebration of our lives a
federal disaster area of the highest
magnitude after the nearly total impact
there of Hurricane Maria and I am
immediately sending to Congress this
presumed presidential message would
continue an emergency relief bill that
will get 1 billion dollars in funds to
this devastated island for relief
efforts no later than Wednesday of this
week with more funds to come in the days
and weeks to follow further one would
believe any president we have ever had
would say I am directing that all
airline passenger vetting processes at
airports there be waived and undertaken
at the passenger destinations instead so
that American citizens in Puerto Rico
who have lost so much and suffered so
greatly already are not also forced to
become prisoners there of the
destruction of the computer systems and
infrastructure there that would
otherwise let them flee to safety that
is what a president would say this
Trump's message about making America
safe is my number one priority continued
we will not admit those into our country
we cannot safely vet it was another
meaningless travel ban that will protect
no one that will save no one that will
help no one and even it was squeezed in
in passing amongst 13 hysterical
self-absorbed lunatic exploitative
nonsensical tweets about whether or not
athletes are standing for the national
anthem or protesting because their
fellow Americans are at mortal risk
because of the policies of this
president not a
word about Puerto Rico not a Trump trip
not a Trump speech not a Trump tweet not
a Trump self-absorbed reference to
having played golf there nothing nothing
not a tweet while a population of 3
million 411,000 Americans Americans
bakes in oppressive heat without power
often without water as the stores run
out as the hospitals run out as
everything runs out three million four
hundred and eleven thousand Americans in
desperate danger an entire island
without electricity perhaps for months
and this tin-pot dictator cannot be
bothered to speak about them a
population of Americans larger than that
in every American city except Los
Angeles and New York a population of
Americans larger than those in the
entire metropolitan areas of Denver and
st. Louis and Pittsburgh and Cleveland
larger than those in the entire states
of Iowa and Mississippi and Maine and 18
others and Trump does nothing in fact he
has done less than nothing a Huffington
Post Capitol Hill reporter tweeted
Monday senior Hill aide says White House
expected to send disaster aid requests
to Congress in first second week of
October for Puerto Rico that gets ball
rolling the first or second week of
October to get the ball rolling how many
will be dead by then Trump is doing
nothing about Puerto Rico and we do not
have to guess why he does nothing says
nothing ignores Americans who first were
drowning and now we'll be dehydrating
and starving how did this monsters
presidential campaign begin with an
assault a verbal dismissal of hispanics
and hispanic americans with the promise
to build a wall to keep them out and
a promise to have a band of
stormtroopers to throw them out and if
you think Donald Trump sees any
difference between Mexican Hispanics and
Puerto Rican Hispanics you are living in
a fool's paradise he sees no difference
in documented immigrants or undocumented
immigrants or Mexican Americans or
Puerto Rican Americans he sees their
skin color and make no mistake about why
he has been silent about them as their
island collapses Donald Trump is letting
Puerto Rico figuratively and literally
die resist remove peace